menschen auf dem boden gerungen oder
brutal ins gesicht geschlagen
immer häufiger tauchen videos von
polizeigewalt in deutschland auf
sechzehnter august der hauptbahnhof von
hannover
polizisten versuchen drei jugendliche
unter kontrolle zu bekommen
sie hatten die verhaftung eines
taschendiebes verhindert die situation
eskaliert als sich eine junge frau
einmischt und von einem der polizisten
gewaltsam weggeschubst wird siebzehnter
august hamburg polizisten gehen auf
einen 15 jährigen los setzen sogar
pfefferspray ein
der 15 jährige war mit einem e roller
auf dem gehweg gefahren widersetzte sich
dann der befragung und legte sich mit
acht polizisten an
die machten kurzen prozess achtzehnter
august sachsenhausen bei frankfurt ein
junger mann liegt hilflos am boden
polizeibeamte knien auf empfang an ihn
zu schlagen er schreit vor schmerzen
doch erst als ein beamter auf den jungen
mann eintritt geht ein polizei kollege
dazwischen
ähnliche bilder vom 17 august in
düsseldorf wieder ein 15-jähriger in der
gewalt der polizei brutal kniet ein
beamter auf dem hals des teenagers in
jedem der fälle wird gegen die beamten
ermittelt doch was auffällt in jedem der
videos setzten die videos erst mit
gewalt seitens der polizei ein
und in jedem der fälle waren die
drangsalierten nicht ganz so unschuldig
wie die videos vorgeben
wenn nun zugeschaltet chefreporter frank
schneider franken gerade als letzten
fall den aus düsseldorf gesehen von
mohamed a dem 15-jährigen du hast jetzt
neue erkenntnisse zu ihm was hast du
bist jetzt erfahren
ja man muss vielleicht mal sagen die
hintergründe genau wo was gerade ein
beitrag gesehen haben
zu diesen personen mit denen die
polizisten sich dort auseinandersetzen
und sie ist auch eben in dem beitrag
brutal gegen diese personen vorgegebenen
muster grundsätzlich erstmal sagen das
so genannte gewalt obwohl die beim start
das heißt polizeibeamte dürfen bei
gegenwehr und wenn ihre maßnahmen
durchzusetzen sind gewalt einsetzen
natürlich immer nur angemessen und das
wird ja jetzt auch in allen fällen
geprüft und wird das gleiche nochmal
hinaus schildern zwischen den fällen
gibt es ja auch deutliche unterschiede
der fall düsseldorf da geht es um das
ist der junge mann mit dem roten t-shirt
dort am boden liegt
da haben jetzt die polizeiakte einsehen
können und dann setzt natürlich
hochinteressant erst 15 momentan seine
kriminelle karriere man muss es leider
so nennen da geht schon mit dreizehn
verprügelt er in einem jugendclub einem
gleichaltrigen so schwer zu boden dass
der banken haus ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert werden muss also regelrecht
krankenhausreif geprügelt
danach geht es weiter dann verprügelt er
seine eigenen mutter ist kommt zum
polizeieinsatz bei ihm zu hause er wird
wegen sachbeschädigung angezeigt wegen
einbruch dann geht er an einem taxistand
in düsseldorf völlig grundlos auf ein
taxi zu mit zwei komplizen wrights die
fahrertür auf und brüllt diesen man dort
an provozierten und beschimpfte ihn als
[ __ ]
der mann lässt sich das natürlich nicht
gefallen steigt dann ausgeht ihnen
hinterher und fragt was das denn solle
daraufhin drehte er sich um und schlägt
ihn unvermittelt mit der faust ins
gesicht und bricht diesen taxifahrer das
nasenbein
dieser fall ist auch bereits angeklagt
da wird sind wir zu einem prozess kommen
wo dann nur mit a sich verantworten muss
und auch bei dem fall hier in düsseldorf
wo ja das video erst beginnt in dem
moment wo die polizisten ihn fixieren
muss man wissen er hat vorher sich
eingemischt eine maßnahme der polizei so
dazwischen gestellt einen polizisten
geschlagen weg geschubst dann hat man
ihn versucht unter kontrolle zu bringen
deshalb auch erst geklappt dann sollte
er sich ausweisen weil aber nur eine
krankenhaus also
krankenversicherungskarte dabei hatte
sollte er dann mitgenommen ins
verwahrung daraufhin hat er sich massiv
gewehrt wahrscheinlich weil ja wussten
die polizisten überprüfen wenn sie auch
aus was auch sonst auf dem kerbholz hat
dann um sich geschlagen sich massiv
gegen die festnahme gestärkt und deshalb
ist er fixiert worden
was natürlich überhaupt nicht heißt dass
die maßnahmen der polizei nicht trotzdem
überprüft werden
denn was ihr einen solchen fällen gern
immer so getan wird als hätten wir
keinen rechtsstaat natürlich prüft die
staatsanwaltschaft der gewaltenteilung
in deutschland diese maßnahmen der
polizist man muss nur einfach auch mal
wissen diese vermeintlichen polizei
opfer manchmal was sie vorher getan
haben wie es zu dieser reaktion der
polizei waren kam und in düsseldorf als
eben auch so er hat massiv um sich
geschlagen und die polizisten wollten
vermeiden dass er weiter polizisten und
kollegen angreifen kann
das ist jetzt gerade gesagt in diesem
fall wird das ganze geprüft man muss
natürlich auch sagen das video hat
schnell an den fall von george floyd in
den usa erinnert und vielleicht auch
dadurch jetzt noch mal größere
schockwellen durch deutschland gebracht
werden auch andere vorfälle gerade
kann es uns einmal da auf den neuesten
stand bringen wie die ermittlungen aus
den falls es welche gibt in den fällen
aus hannover hamburg die wir gerade
gesehen haben ja ich möchte jetzt
nochmal immer einen genau diesen
vergleichen mit george wright wir müssen
ja mal sagen es gibt eine ganz
entscheidende unterschied lodge leute
ist leider gottes verstorben
dort hat der polizist massiv gewalt
gegen den hals aus das ist hier nicht
passiert der anwalt des jungen mannes
hat natürlich behauptet sein mandant sei
auch mit einem stellte irgendeiner
verletzung multiple prellungen
man muss aber auch da wiederum wissen
bereits am nächsten tag ist dann eine
polizeimaßnahme geraten bei einer
massenschlägerei mit nackten oberkörper
posiert vor dem polizisten und stolz
erklärt er sei der georgetown aus der
altstadt und noch am gleichen tag 20
minuten nach den vorfällen die wir auch
bereits wieder durch die altstadt des
beweisen überwachungsvideos und bei der
kontrollaktion einen tag nach der tat
haben ihnen auch gefragt er wieder
draußen rumlaufen er sei doch angeblich
verletzt hätten sie gehört nur wenig
verletzte ging ist gut
auch das muss man vielleicht mal
berücksichtigen wenn man jetzt sieht was
der anwalt behauptet wie schwer doch
sein mandant angeblich verletzt und
traumatisiert
bei den anderen fällen ich habe bereits
gesagt man muss klar differenzieren der
fall in frankfurt ist in meinen augen
relativ klar gelagert da tritt ein
polizist den am boden liegenden das
reden ist man sieht ja auch hervor dass
kollegen dazwischen gehen ihm
wegschieben
dort haben auch eigene kollegen bereits
ein ja eine anzeige gegen ihn gefertigt
bevor überhaupt das video öffentlich
wurde also da hat sozusagen der
kontrollmechanismus unter innerhalb der
polizei hat funktioniert der fall in
hamburg ist so gelagert dass er sich
auch massiv gesperrt hat was genau da
der hintergrund war ist unklar
das video setzt ja auch erst in dem
moment an wo die polizisten aktiv werden
es gibt die langfassung auch im internet
und da sieht man eben dass er vor massiv
er ist groß sehr kräftig massiv auf
polizisten und insbesondere die beiden
polizisten ein schlägt auch das muss man
wissen ob das sieht man hier nicht
und dann haben wir natürlich noch diese
sogenannte tumult lage in dem u
bahnsteig
auch da muss man sich vorstellen ist
natürlich immer hinterher schöne zeiten
wo so ein video zu analysieren aber das
sind mehrere personen durch den dann
aber weiß überhaupt nicht wer ist täter
wer ist opfer es geht völlig
durcheinander alle schreien schubsen
fallen übereinander her und die
polizisten versuchen erstmal die
personen zu trennen
überhaupt die übersicht zu bekommen und
man muss ja auch wissen nach den
übergriffen der letzten monate gegen
polizei bad gastein ganz in der
moderation gesagt ein polizist natürlich
auch immer die sorge täter können auch
möglicherweise abgebrochene bierflasche
messer ähnliches gegen sie einsetzen
deswegen versuchen sie immer die person
auf distanz zu halten
denn nur dann können sie möglichst
sicher in den einsatz gehen und das
ihnen oder ihren kollegen nichts
passiert und das ist natürlich sehr
brutal aussieht wie er die frau
workshops völlig klar ist auch immer die
frage musste das in dem moment sein
warum einfach mal zu erklären warum es
in diesen situationen zu diesem tumulten
bord alle schreien durcheinander fallen
übereinander her und die polizisten
kommen und müssen erst mal versuchen
irgendwie wird auch noch einzubringen
aber wie gesagt alle pferde werden durch
staatsanwaltschaften geprüft in
deutschland herrscht gewaltenteilung uns
herrscht ein rechtsstaat und es wird in
den einzelfällen alle sind alles
überprüft uns wird auch völlig klar sein
in frankfurt gehe ich den felsen der
fest davon aus dass der polizeibeamte
auch ein verfahren bekommen wird wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzungen